well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Tom Segura Christina the ship's
to your house well you know I love to go
know this but I'm Polly mm-hmm and I'm
bi
and I'm also non-binary here I'm proud
to have come out of this polyamorous and
now I'm excited to share that I'm
bisexual
yeah I'm non-binary to the non-binary
for those of you don't know what the
term means I'm surprised if you don't I
mean who isn't non-binary those days
right President Obama went to London and
was taking taking questions from the
audience and a Pakistani person came out
as non-binary to President Obama and
that was on Twitter and we were like
what's non-binary yeah it means neither
gender correct yeah it means you're you
don't identify fully with yeah male or
female totally non-binary yeah all right
you feel like that totally hmm I'm like
I'm Demi Demi gendered I've you know
yeah interesting yeah interesting I
don't know I mean I don't know there's
so much there's so many different
genders there are a lot I'm gonna see
what my dad thinks if we can get him on
the phone but I'll see that's the best
part about the stuff is asking our dads
what they think about these genders yeah
new new gender norms
I hope the answers so it was really
telling him the first time
hello mom Tommy you were calling in the
other line of course what I was trying
to call the bed and I hear I'd say
that's why I don't recognize it does not
your phone no yeah yeah it's gone from
my other phone I have to a few phones
here so I talked to one three and I said
he has to be a self my son by trying to
mean both for children hey yeah I wanted
to tell you something I'm really excited
about I'm Polly and I'm bi and I'm
non-binary you know what I'm Pollyanna
by and I'm non-binary this is what I
understand I'm falling and I'm bi
and then don't binary so I like if I put
it together into Chinese I'm polyamorous
I'm bisexual and I'm non-binary yet
you're bisexual
yeah but I'm also don't you because
gender then going to become to a unit or
you complete the whole picture mouth no
but I'm non-viability knife she doesn't
you're not buying I'm I'm non-binary
gender binaries your guess by pictures
no no I I don't identify as either male
or female
I'm just I don't I don't identify as
either gender
so I provide you cannot go to the bottom
of the shoe to be sure to go party
before you go
you're totally screwed you're not either
one I'm here unless just get prompt
unless we get Trump granted there's a
chance she's want to respect your but
you're nothing
are you a trump in that I am I'm not a
nobody I mean this is awful it's
embarrassing
yeah absolutely the idea that I'm on a
watch he'll a talking is the most fake
politician Authority hi this mine and it
is a typical politician
we wanted to hear the way under which I
don't see open TPP I don't have anything
so that is a not straight boy that
doesn't have a clue how to run the
country I would love to see a resident
Kasich yeah yeah the only guy deferment
on it's completely knowledgeable and if
you have cadiz management and either
yeah and all right Danny who could you
like and I think you want Hillary um I
want I'd rather have just another
non-binary person leaving the country
you know yeah why don't you run well
that's the thing I'm that's the other
announcement I wanted to tell you that
I'm probably gonna run for president
mom it's not a joke I think it totally
threw it away because I'm coming oh I
can do
Oh Oh Christian you already got that the
photo pull apart Christina wanted to
tell you wanted me to well she's here
but she wanted to tell you about the
shower we took the other day because
she's been like I'm gonna tell your
mother because we took a shower together
here at El tell her baby could she hear
me yeah oh hi thank you hi creepy man
so your son and not any about it yeah
you're gonna love this your son and I
thought it would be romantic and loving
to take a shower together and I can
almost I can almost guess what you did
what do you think happened I think he
thought farting on poop came out clothes
no I'm right he spread his butt cheeks
to get the water on it he used the bar
of soap uh he put the bar in his
butthole ahead of you taking ah ah God
please
3232 storm no I'm fighting pain is so
exhausting okay I think I think my
husband would enjoy it but we put out of
him weight gets better and then give me
a get work no I got better it gets worse
so then he starts whore Caylor like
Hawking a loogie ah dad uh no and then
he blows not he he puts one
one nostril and pushes the snot out of
the kitchen I that's enough I can't even
get there maybe I can be nice yeah yeah
and then this is like a minute I don't
have to hear it anymore
oh no I promise you and then the snot
wasn't his beard and then he peed on me
he peed on me in this high I can't
imagine anything with that imagination
nevertheless I'm to discontent this is
disgusting saying Tom like 70 years of
life I ever heard and you think this is
funny I don't think it's funny I think
it's horrible I think we were trying to
have I wasn't you think what button for
drive making yes for me that she's not
by me I mean no miss but he's nothing
he's by sexual but doesn't qualify and
you don't mind he's my picture by the
way I was it yeah he's well he's Polly
he's polyamorous bisexual buddy's
non-binary so he's not attracted to
either sex oh I thought you already
kitchen see so he's wanted did my
picture if you did right well he's also
non-binding I like can't I like both
sexes but I'm neither sex right he's
asexual
alright here's I dieted bully can HM do
something with you for me
can I tell you something very hurtful
that Christina did well after we took
that shower she told me that I was like
I that I was a homeless person that I
the death that it was like a shower with
a homeless person isn't that rude wait
am homeless bird yeah she said that
showering with me is like showering with
a homeless person because I'm sliding
and why I do he was not the great into
homeless people and why is god I don't
know what she means with it home this
bedroom house her but they call me first
on it's clean and she's taking each
other so what is wrong ask her about her
if she noticed that he was washing the
comfort anything oh that's right that's
true that's a good point mom hey
dad told me the other day that he farted
on the bed and that there was shit on
the bedspread a bit it's true
and what did you think it was when you
heard this no I walk in the house and I
see if I've got in the comforters in the
washing machine I guess wash it you
forget but I guess problems and what
these are what it was it wasn't
naturally I think but I I had a little
fun and he came it was one of the father
didn't noise yes another part so I did
you know that those are my do you know
that those are called a char do you know
they're called a shart
I have no interesting only the name oh
good because if I have one though I have
been bout I go to a bathroom no no it's
called a sharp on huge but it's called a
shark
yeah shark SH a RT it's shark okay kinda
sharp thing right because when you go to
fart but you shit so it's a shart or
usually you have one of both wetter than
when you say I like it if it happens if
you get on their work we could go
through your and the word suit to the
pants into the bed then you poop in your
bunch of him so that's a good point
actually that's a good boy we cannot
disturb ya helping you go through so
much is that now do you get distinction
did you it's a very important
distinction did it bother you that he
didn't remove the poop stains from the
bedspread he just put with the chunks of
poop into the washer would you mind to
change the topic of conversation it is
so disgusting
but I know blowing up a bit I was in
deep coal I was having a cup of coffee
with a coffee cake yeah I was calling
the set for my dog I hang out to the bed
to seek food dispersal is calling me to
both numbers it has to be something
important yes I heard somebody who
wanted to go for few days because they
are not inconvenient but that's
inconvenient that called you when you
want to a big fella bullshit and duper
buy it right but I tend to be you to
talk about poop which if you get worse
or we're talking but we're worried about
you
I'm mourning having even daily you
haven't even kidding me hold the baby
with the only baby he's in the crate
right now he's in is explain that yes
yeah he's locked up give it green
you're so busy not being bite this and
not these but that but you're not a
polybag yet a deal
what is it is now I'm Paulina by but I'm
also 9 but non-binary guy poorly
yeah and by I'm it I'm bi and non-binary
I'm going binary non-binary non-binary
and what is nominate I don't identify as
either gender that's very sad it gives
you nothing money no you don't know
here's the thing when you refer to me
you don't say he like you don't go he
would like to do that you say they so if
somebody says they like your Kuya right
oh right yes can I say it you are
nothing
actually you're not babe when you
clarify this again you guys on top of
English so here are not invade your it
couldn't nothing
now you having a poison identify like
this and you don't want to die like that
so you're it that's a little hurtful but
ok within my kitchen table and do
neither one is nothing well I don't know
if I'm your kitchen table I'm telling
you I don't if you and you have no
feelings you're not attracted to either
one you are not bisexual you are not
holding you're not believe you're not
Bali you're not doing yeah I guess that
that's not bad you're not two people the
opposite you are reducing yourself to it
we prefer they what I'm talking for me
it's telling a day they are not the
people in there tell her we're making
day and you know you want to be both and
she got in mind and be Chara we're
making sure to raise Ellis in a non
gender conformist environment to we're
going to dress him up in painting that
that right now you get some of your
joking what I mean what if you know I
don't wanted to grab it confused yeah
what kind of can I pick up the baby I'm
not too good I shot some treatments
making a couple of years I get back
well when he's done playing with his dog
yeah maybe I'm sorry I think I think she
prefers to be in a normal environment
which I would care what she thought
maybe we have a different definition of
normal
yeah but I know what's on my date
because I'm only eight million years
older when do I know normal okay
no no whatever changing the topic of our
conversation by the eyes yeah yeah we
went to the movie just of it and I love
the movie Christina you will love it
what is it what my name is
Baldy my name is dolly or Paul wrong
pony dolly well he was Dolly in PI my
name is Polly by know my name is bodis
Norris Oh Doris okay I love it
what's what what is it about yeah what's
it about uh well this is an older woman
yeah yeah she works on here Takashi my
younger guy I watched him go through it
I mean it hit acting is superb I mean
they don't give Oscar for the type of
fighting virtually we fell for it
fantastic job
a little bit I forgot no it's not the
movie to show my guys was a very moving
area and you should know as a movie that
it's a good thing that you laughing
anything good about my cool we'll check
it out when they make a poly by version
but mom can I call you back on the other
line yeah I want to talk about a bitch
yeah no no we'll talk baby stuff and
everything I gotta go take a shit yeah
I'll call you when I'm done with this
thing don't think they creatures because
you never choose he does it in the
budget
yeah I know excuse me excuse me no heat
no heat can be sure the eight that's it
in the best there you go hey you're
getting there I'm finally yeah all right
they love you like a peanut Barbara I
love you right bye
well you know we should do when they
come visit neck look then it's dangerous
but I'll thick your neck but oh there
there you go big wu-tang clan my mom